hi my name is Venki  I passed the competition and now work in  organizational development in human  resources in my job we make the  Commission more efficient to meet  Europe's challenges and we also try to  engage people and motivate our  colleagues I enjoy working with  motivated and brilliant colleagues from  all over Europe and I can learn  something new every day in my job the EU  as an employer offers a vast range of  opportunities I like living in Brussels  it's a vibrating City with many things  to do and to discover the next  competition is coming up I know it's  tough but it's worth it give it a try if  you enjoyed this video please like share  and subscribe to our Channel